[Music]  Warner Brothers has rare directors cuts  of the holiday classics that we all grew  up watching all right and we get to see  some of the scenes that were gonna be in  that were cut out at the last minute  that no one's ever seen before so check  out this never-before-seen ending which  was edited out but we have the original  Miracle on 34th Street this is the  original ending leave this office  immediately and an Isaac now vitiligo  Street tombs to Maci and tell him what a  malicious contemptible fraud you are get  out before I have you thrown out there's  only one way to handle a man like you  [Applause]  [Music]  you guys like that ending better yeah I  said it kills it he's like I'm shutting  down here coward all right